this video is kindly sponsored by
curiositystream the subscription
streaming service that offers thousands
of documentaries and non-fiction titles
from some of the world's best filmmakers
hey 42 here we humans like to think of
ourselves as being pretty smart in fact
most of us wouldn't hesitate to call
ourselves members of the most
intelligent species on earth but what if
i were to tell you that there's an
organism out there that can solve
complex mathematical problems
more efficiently than many advanced
algorithms and design city transport
systems that rival and sometimes improve
upon those built by the world's best
city planners this remarkable creature
even earns itself a faculty position at
a u.s college just in case those feats
of intellect don't impress you i should
also mention that this organism can
self-heal if you chop it in half
and it can do all of these remarkable
things despite the fact it consists of a
single cell and lacks a brain come to
think of it it doesn't have any organs
like
none but before i get onto this
genuinely remarkable little critter what
exactly do we mean by intelligence
anyway
it's hard to pin down a precise
definition of the word but most
interpretations revolve around an
organism's ability to learn and solve
problems whilst it's true that most
humans are good at both of these things
intelligence is by no means a uniquely
human trait
far from it in fact many of the
behaviors we consider to be uniquely
human like language culture and tool use
are not unique to us at all
take dolphins for example these majestic
creatures call each other by name in the
form of signature whistles and they even
use sponges to protect their beaks when
foraging for food amongst sharp rocks
they've also learnt that when used in
small doses puffer fish toxins can be
enjoyed as a narcotic the most
rebellious dolphins have been caught
passing the puffers behind the back of
the proverbial bike sheds each taking a
hit
before floating up to the surface to
gaze dizzily at their own reflections
having said that don't try this at home
one puffer fish contains enough toxin to
kill 30 adult humans and there is no
known antidote there's no known antidote
for stupidity either so don't say i
didn't warn you intelligent behavior
doesn't stop at mammals either octopuses
can use tools open jars
juggle hermit crabs that's a pretty neat
trick when you've got eight arms and
even play with lego
one thing these creatures have in common
is a brain well nine if we're talking
about the octopus which has one big
central brain and one mini brain in each
arm but intelligent behavior has been
demonstrated in organisms without any
brains at all
plants for example can learn to ignore
stressful stimuli
if they're repeatedly exposed to them
without being harmed they also
communicate with each other to mount
defenses against insect invasions and
can even identify other plant species
using sound
but whilst they don't have brains plants
are still highly complex organisms made
up of millions of different cells what
about simpler species
or even single-celled organisms could
they possibly be seen as intelligent too
enter the slime mold
the undisputed einstein of the single
cell world
slime molds are a diverse group of
amoeba-like creatures that spend most of
their life cycle as a single cell but
when stressed they can band together to
form much larger multi-celled
collectives that function as what you
might call a super organism
a megazord of the animal kingdom despite
their name these unusual organisms
aren't actually molds at all they're
protists a fifth kingdom of life
separate from animals plants fungi and
bacteria that is reserved by biologists
for
everything we don't really understand
there's over 900 species of slime mold
and they can be found everywhere from
the antarctic to the namib desert many
are invisible to the naked eye but some
can be seen as large gooey blobs that
ooze from the forest floor including the
lurid yellow dog's vomit slime mold and
the pearly white cacada luna which
directly translates to moon poo for all
their abilities branding is not a slime
mold strong suit
curiosity stream is the world's first
streaming service addressing our
lifelong quest to learn explore and
understand if like me you're into
history you definitely need to check out
their content packed history selection
but history is only a small part of
their enormous collection with content
spanning science nature technology
society and lifestyle it really is the
new netflix for nerds it's hulu for
history buffs and the disney plus for
the scientists in all of us despite
having an enormous amount of titles
curiosity stream is extremely affordable
it's under 20 dollars a year and it's
available worldwide and practically on
every device one of my favorite shows is
google and the world brain it's a
fascinating look behind the scenes at
google's attempt to scan and digitize
every single book in the world but it
raises some interesting and
controversial questions about what they
plan to do with all of that so if you're
anything like me and you love to learn
new things then you should check it out
go to curiositystream.com
forward slash 40
for unlimited access to the world's top
documentaries and non-fiction series
you can also use my promo code 42 and
you will save 25
which comes out to only 14.99 a year
considering how unbelievably affordable
it is compared to other streaming
services it's an absolute no-brainer
perhaps the most well-studied of the
slimes is physarium polycephalum an
enormous yellow single cell that can
grow to over a foot in diameter it
contains thousands of nuclei and is able
to explore its surroundings by fanning
out its body in a network of finger-like
tendrils moving at speeds of up to five
centimeters per hour that might not
sound very speedy to you but it's pretty
good going for a single cell in the wild
foserum can be found foraging for
bacteria and fungi on the damp dark
forest floor it avoids light and dryness
and in the lab it's also been shown to
have a particular ponchon for oats
and oddly enough valerian sleeping pills
by coaxing the slime mold with these
tantalizing treats
scientists have been able to demonstrate
some surprisingly savvy skills from this
simple single-celled slime
first off it can solve puzzles
when outflakes are placed at the
entrance and exits to a maze the slime
consistently finds the shortest path
between them this discovery earned
toshiyuki nakagaki and his team at
hokkaido university the egg nobel prize
for cognition in 2008 a subcategory of
the annual awards for research that
first makes you laugh but then makes you
think
other notable prizes that year included
the discovery that flees living on dogs
jump higher than those living on cats
and the observation that professional
lap dancers earn higher tips when
they're ovulating you're welcome it's
this remarkable maze-solving ability
that has seen slime molds outperform
modern computers in some really complex
tasks notably in tackling the famous
travelling salesman problem the premise
of the problem is simple
given several cities spaced at random
what's the shortest route a salesman
could take to visit them all once
traditionally classical computers brute
force this problem which means that the
time to solve it increases exponentially
as more cities are added since computers
have to test every single possible route
but scientists have found that slime
molds tackle the problem in an entirely
different way
meaning their solve time only increases
linearly as more cities are added single
celled and simple they may be but slime
molds are literally teaching us humans
how to make more efficient computers
hokkaido's slime squad actually received
another egg nobel prize just two years
later this time they'd given the slime a
complicated networking problem to solve
it was challenged to create an energy
efficient yet resilient network between
36 outflakes that might sound like a
fairly abstract task but there was
method to this ot madness
by using light to simulate geographical
limitations such as mountains and lakes
these 36 oat flakes represented 36 main
towns and cities surrounding tokyo the
slime molds task was simple to build the
most efficient route between the oat
flakes representing the optimal
transport network possible the central
slime blob was placed in the position of
tokyo itself
meaning it was faced with a similar
challenge to the one that had taken
japan's
best transport engineers
years to overcome in just over a day the
slime mold had mapped out an efficient
network between the oats that looked
strikingly similar to tokyo's actual
railway system since then the slime has
been tested on many other transport
systems around the world the resulting
networks shared the most similarity with
the highly efficient transport routes in
china belgium and canada the slime
agreed less with the uk's historic train
lines
and seem to think that america's
interstate highway should be re-routed
altogether i'm sure he's not alone on
that one the slime's behavior has also
been used to develop mathematical models
which could be used to improve the
efficiency of future transport networks
in fact similar slime models have
already been put to work across all
sorts of disciplines from predicting the
location of ancient roman road networks
to the production of three-dimensional
maps of the invisible cosmic web that
underlies the very fabric of our local
universe not bad for a brainless blob
but how does all of this actually work i
mean this is an organism with no brain
no thoughts no will no intelligence or
at least not in any sense that we would
recognize
how can it possibly solve complicated
problems that even we humans
master race of planet earth find
challenging
to form their network slime molds move
using a system of pulsating tissue
which allows them to communicate
information throughout their bodies when
they detect something they like such as
food the cell expands in the area
nearest the attractant
reducing the internal pressure of the
region
which causes the rest of the cell's
contents to move towards it down the
newly created pressure gradient the
opposite happens when slime molds
encounter something they're less keen on
this is all very well in the lab where
conditions can be controlled
but natural environments tends to
present a much more complicated
assortment of stimuli than simply this
way good that way bad for example if a
food source is really high quality it
might be worth foraging for in a
slightly riskier environment like one
with too much light or too little
moisture which is why slime molds have
developed the ability to assess
environmental trade-offs to figure out
the least bad option in a given set of
circumstances or even completely ignore
stimuli they perceive as unpleasant
things like caffeine or quinine
if the payoff is big enough this type of
learning is called habituation and it's
something we humans do all the time we
quickly learn to filter out a relevant
stimuli in our lives from the feeling of
our clothes against our skin
to the constant stream of tweets from
problematic politicians
and in the same way that we share newly
acquired knowledge with our friends and
family the adaptive responses of a slime
mold can be transferred from one slime
cell to another by simply fusing the two
together that's right these
single-celled organisms are able to
learn from one another
they also have memories despite not
possessing literally any of the physical
apparatus we associate with the
formation of memories
as slime molds move they leave behind a
thin layer of extracellular ooze which
allows them to recognize and avoid areas
they've already explored
a bit like hansel and gretel's
breadcrumbs but with more slime they
also anticipate regular changes in their
surroundings
even keeping track of the time at which
these changes took place we know this
because when a slime cell is exposed to
pulses of cold dry air at hourly
intervals it soon learns to slow down
its movement in an effort to avoid the
next pulse even when no new cold air is
applied
today some scientists are harnessing the
slime's predictable problem solving for
use in new technologies slime molds have
already been used to control the
movements of small robots by acting as a
simple biological brain for the robot's
artificial body the slime's output is a
direct result of the input it receives
from sensors on the machine's surface
meaning that when the robot is exposed
to bright light it tends to scuttle away
into the shadows acting just like its
slimy puppeteer
but the most exciting application of
slime robotics lies in the cell's
ability to use not just current inputs
but also past events
to decide how to behave
it's this capacity which allows the
slime mold to play the piano well sort
of
eduardo miranda is a computer scientist
and musician at plymouth university on a
mission to shake up the music industry
he is sick and tired of cookie cutter
factory produced pop icons and instead
believes it's time for his act the piano
playing slime mould to top the charts
well something like that anyway the
contraption he's rigged up to his piano
allows him to convert the sound
vibrations of the strings
into small electrical signals which can
then be fed to a slime-based circuit the
slime responds by changing its body
shape creating an answering electrical
signal which triggers some of the
electromagnets above the piano strings
causing them to vibrate
in this way miranda and the slime mold
are able to duet with each consecutive
phrase miranda plays
the slime modifies its response based on
both the most recent musical melody and
the electrical signals of the previous
notes that were played to it
the resulting composition is
spooky and overworldly but the slime's
responsive tinkling
has a strangely musical quality
beyond creating these slimy symphonies
the cell's ability to remember the
amount of charge that has previously
passed through it could have much wider
reaching applications
the slime in miranda circuit is
effectively acting as a mem resistor an
electronic component that's able to
retain data without a power supply
mem resistors can store more data than
today's solid-state storage technologies
in a smaller space whilst using less
energy integrating slime based
components into our computers laptops
and phones
could satisfy our demand for data whilst
using smaller devices and less power and
there's more the synapses in our brains
that allow impulses to pass between
neurons can be seen as biological mem
resistors therefore it's not
inconceivable that integrating slime
molds into future electronics could
allow us to develop robots with similar
processing capabilities to the human
brain and since they'd be slime based
they'd also be self-assembling and
self-repairing
like all biological systems slime molds
have evolved their impressive
problem-solving prowess over millions of
years of natural selection some might
argue that the slime mold is simply
following the laws of chemistry and
physics to perform well in their chosen
environments
but at the end of the day
aren't we all whilst it was admittedly a
bit of a publicity stunt the unique
intelligence of slime molds led to one
of them being granted a faculty position
at hampshire college in massachusetts
the position came complete with a
dedicated office and several student
research assistants who were tasked with
helping their slime mold boss solve
complex political issues like border
policy offshore drilling and drug
regulation
seriously
our human centric view of the world has
undoubtedly constrained our appreciation
of the accomplishments of other species
yet intelligent behavior can be seen
across the tree of life and recognizing
it as such could provide us with
inspiration
for revolutionary new tools transport
and technologies
thanks for watching
check out my new podcast random
interesting facts available on youtube
spotify apple podcast and anywhere else
you get your podcasts link in the
description below thanks